time for others but we're going to
describe we're going to talk about
abscam and and what it is american
hustle the movie that's out is about
abscam a little bit
um but on february 2nd 1980 nbc news
broadcast a report about appscam
good evening nbc news has learned of an
extraordinary story of political
corruption involving 20 public officials
all who accepted bribes from fbi
personnel posing as influence buyers one
senator is involved and six congressmen
brian ross reports from washington
for almost a year now this house in an
expensive residential section of
washington dc has been a center of an
elaborate fbi undercover investigation
of political corruption codenamed
operation abscam
an fbi undercover agent living in the
house and posing as a businessman with
arab money backing him drove around
washington in a big limousine through
lavish parties entertain politicians and
the fbi says paid out hundreds of
thousands of dollars in bribes in cash
to public officials
this house is just one of a number of
locations in five cities where
undercover fbi agents are reported to
have paid out more than one million
dollars in bribes all recorded on
videotape
more than 20 public officials are
believed to have been implicated in the
fbi operation including six congressmen
one united states senator and the number
of local officials from philadelphia new
york and new jersey
today teams of fbi agents numbering more
than 100 confronted as many of the
public officials as they could find the
evidence against them
late today the fbi said it would have no
comment on operation abscam
but investigators say later this month
federal grand juries will begin hearing
testimony from the undercover fbi agents
who worked on the case and investigators
already calling operation abscam the
most important investigation of
political corruption since watergate
brian ross nbc news washington
and now joining us in our new york
studio is gregory wallace former
assistant u.s attorney for new york from
1979 to 1985.
mr wall lance how did abscam get started
well it got started in a pretty humble
way it was an operation run out of the
fbi office in hop hog long island
and it was aimed at low-level crooks who
had stolen art and securities
and the ruse was as the news report
indicated that a very wealthy arab sheik
was prepared to buy stolen cds and
stolen art and make investments
and pay off politicians
and
no one at that time ever dreamed that it
would result in the conviction
of six congressmen a united states
senator and a host of lesser officials
how did it get to
bribery charges against congressman and
senator
well at the core of abscam
was a professional con man
named mel weinberg and in american
hustle he's played by christian bale
and he was cooperating with the
investigation with the sting operation
in order to avoid uh charges or get
lighter
sentence for charges of fraud and
he made abscam come alive he could
create an illusion that he was working
for a very wealthy sheik he convinced
people that the sheik
had an enormous amount of money to
spread around and mind you this was at a
time
after the
oil boycotts
by the middle eastern oil producers
where oil prices had shot through the
roof
it had made the
the gulf states in particular saudi
arabia quite wealthy and so it wasn't
that hard to convince people that yes
there's a wealthy chic out there with a
lot of money and essentially it was a
little bit like flies to honey
uh word got around and the lower level
crooks that they were dealing with put
them in touch
with higher level
people uh lawyers with contacts with
congressmen and senators uh city
councilman the mayor of camden new
jersey angelo richetti was a key figure
and so it was a kind of a form of
of underworld networking
and they just kept moving higher and
higher or using the underworld analogy
lower and lower uh and the turning point
the key event
in what turned appscan from a local
sting operation to a national one
was angelo erichetti the mayor of camden
new jersey now in in the movie and i i
thought american hustle was a great
movie and i thoroughly enjoyed it but in
the movie he's portrayed somewhat
sympathetically as reluctant in fact at
one point
christian bale the mel weinberg
character has to go and bring him back
into a meeting where bribes are being
paid or discussed
and at the end there's a certain amount
of sympathy generated for him when he
when he ends up kind of getting caught
in this thing but
in fact
mayor angelo or ketty was about as
corrupt as they come early on
he gave the undercover operatives
lists of new jersey public officials and
public officials from elsewhere who he
said were willing to sell their offices
for cash
he was willing to engage in any kind of
a scheme counterfeiting from
counterfeiting to bribery even at one
point he was discussing well turning the
port of camden into a narcotics entry
point
and one judge the judge who presided
over the most of the abscam trials
called him a cesspool of corruption but
to the abscam operatives he was a you
know he was a goldmine because he was
the one
who put them in touch with many of the
congressmen and with the uh united
states senator harrison williams
who ultimately uh agreed to take bribes
or to use their
uh their office to influence uh in
effect uh
uh
use their influence to get legislative
favors for the sheik and his his
operatives
and
that's where i do take issue with the
movie
uh as good a movie as it was was that
that was not an accurate portrayal
mr wallant you write in a recent uh
piece for usa today that the sting was a
mix of slap dash improvisation and near
vaudeville showmanship
uh
was it a sting was it were these
congressmen and senators set up
well they weren't set up in the sense
that they were
induced
to
engage in illegal acts that they weren't
otherwise predisposed to do and that's
that's the definition of entrapment and
that was what some some of the
congressmen asserted the entrapment
defense
uh rather it's it's well established in
the law and for many many decades that
there's nothing improper in law
enforcement setting up an opportunity or
a means
for
a criminal
or someone who's disposed to criminal
activity to commit a crime
and that's lawful and in fact i think
undercover operations sting operations
play a play a very very important role
particularly when it comes to
consensual crimes by that i mean crimes
where there are no victims who can then
notify law enforcement when you're
talking about bribery the bribe payer
and the bribe receiver
are in it together and they're not going
to go then and say well something
terrible is taking place so often the
only way you can find out it's going on
is to in effect
set up a sting operation an undercover
operation participate
in the bribery activity
and indeed record it which often means
you're going to get very reliable
evidence and in this case abscam
recorded both with
audio audio and video recordings that
left no question about what had happened
and the issue that came up was were
these congressmen and these senators
entrapped
and when you watch him on the tape
the congressman who comes in and says
let me tell you something real simple
and short
you guys are going about this the right
way money talks and [ __ ] walks and
then he takes fifty thousand dollars in
a cash envelope and puts it in his
pocket another congressman walked in and
said uh i've got larceny in my heart i'm
no boy scout and took the money
and a third congressman walked in he
took the cash put it in his
inside jacket pocket or in his pants
pockets patted it down and asked the con
the the undercover operatives does it
show
so this wasn't the case where
mel weinberg
for example or the other fbi operatives
were pied pipers leading children
by throwing candy in their path
to some terrible fate
these were highly sophisticated
politicians many of them were
powerful or in charge of powerful
committees they were used to
dealing with uh strong personalities to
saying no
uh to engaging in give and take and
holding their own
and they could have at any point
said no this is wrong and in fact
one or two did
although
in those instances they were pretty
polite about it and they never reported
that they had been approached
by an arab sheikh
who asked them to commit an illegal act
they never went to the fbi and said you
need to look into this
nonetheless
as compared to those congressmen who who
did take the money
uh they became practically uh national
heroes which
some people at the time thought was sort
of a sad commentary that taking turning
down a bride makes you a hero as opposed
to
uh taking one and that was a quote from
larry pressler well
one of the congressmen targeted was a
well-known figure here in washington who
served for a long time after this abscam
investigation that was john mirtha i
want to show you a little bit of the
fbi's hidden video of john murphy now
there's some language in here that uh
some may find offensive but uh here's a
video from the late seventies john
mirtha
now
introducing legislation is only
legitimate if the guys in your district
because otherwise you got a real problem
well that would be no problem to move in
the addition that's right i mean
he could buy something there you're
talking about a residence of some sort
right i'm talking about no i'm not going
to ask you about that
business commitment that makes it
imperative for me to help him just let
me tell you something i'm sure if
there's a lot of things i've done up
here with environmental regulations with
all kinds of waivers of laws and
regulations that if if it weren't in a
district people would say well that son
of a [ __ ] i'm going to tell you
something this guy is uh
you know on a take well once they say
that what happens then they start going
around looking for the goddamn money so
i want to avoid that by having some
tithe in the district that's all that's
gregory wall lance what were we watching
there
well you're watching a congressman
turn down a bribe
but doing it in a way that left open the
door
to perhaps an arrangement of some kind
that would accomplish the same objective
without being so so obvious ultimately
congressman murtha was not prosecuted
uh and it it still nonetheless
raised some questions
and i'm not certain that he ever got out
from under that that cloud but that was
an example of
how a congressman if he wanted to
could say no could decline a bribe
and in the case of the six congressmen
who were convicted and the united states
senator who was convicted uh they chose
not to do that they chose it
deliberately and they acted in in a way
as though they didn't look nervous
they didn't look uneasy they didn't look
as though somehow you know their will
was being overborn
or they couldn't resist
they were helpless to resist the money
they had a kind of a dignified matter of
fact aplomb about how they went about
taking the money and engaging with
the undercover operatives who were very
clear in their role as the sheik's
emissaries that they were thoroughly
corrupt and
they didn't look as though they were
doing this for the first time and i i
think that's what convinced the juries
that they weren't being entrapped
uh which is that that they were so
comfortable in the way they went about
it and you know i might add that most of
the congressmen
did not assert the entrapment defense
namely i did something i was
not predisposed to do and and the one of
the reasons i think they didn't
tactically
you know go down that road was because
in order to assert
the entrapment defense you have to admit
you committed the crime
and then you say but i was induced to do
it
by these these undercover agents and so
for
a politician holding high office that's
a difficult
feat to pull off
and and so some of them came in with
defenses that that were
well for example one argued or claimed
that actually he was conning the sheikh
he never intended to introduce the
legislation that the sheik was
ostensibly paying for
that he was pulling his own con on the
con and another came in and said well i
was conducting my own investigation
and i was getting evidence and i was
going to report it to the fbi
and and the defenses in some ways were
almost as outlandish as as the crimes
that they were accused of but
nonetheless
from uh i think from a prosecutor's
point of view
uh the ultimate test is
does a jury believe beyond a reasonable
doubt
that these individuals are not entrapped
and that they and or that they committed
the crime and
every jury that listened to the
testimony every jury returned a
conviction
and every appellate court to review the
fairness
of both the investigation and of the
trial affirm those convictions
and that's i think is ultimately was the
stamp of approval
on on abscam and
you know to my thinking uh made it one
of the most effective
undercover operations of political crime
in uh in our country's history what was
your role in abscam
well right after that news report
in early 1980
and i was a relatively new assistant u.s
attorney
i was in effect assigned to work as part
of the trial team
and i spent the next two years
in pre-trial preparation i listened to a
lot of those those tapes
and and then i participated in the
trials and then in the appellate process
and at that point i was just a few years
out of law school and it was quite an
experience to
come into that kind of uh
of a case and quite eye-opening
listening to those tapes and the way
people talked uh when
they didn't think they were being
watched
do you think that sting operations you
think the word sting is is fair first of
all and do you think sting operations
like this against government officials
is a fair way of doing business from the
prosecutorial side
well sting is simply a euphemism for an
undercover operation in which the
undercover operatives
assume the role of a criminal in some
way
and yes i do think that it's a fair way
to conduct investigations after amscam
for example there was an operation
another undercover operation in chicago
which investigated corruption judiciary
and used similar techniques a different
setting and resulted in the convictions
of a dozen or more very corrupt judges
but these these operations are not
without their risks and a lot depends on
the judgment
of the agents and the prosecutors who
are
are handling them i'll give you an
example
of a sting operation that i think much
more than anything that american hustle
was addressing
illustrates the ambiguous the moral
ambiguity of some if if you recall in
1965
after the selma montgomery voting rights
march
a white woman who had been participating
in the march
viola liuzu
was shot
and killed
that was a huge event
and it probably was a very strong
contributing factor to the
to the change in in the voting rights
laws
the people who the men who shot her were
apprehended and convicted now why was
that
the reason is that sometime earlier the
fbi
had infiltrated
an fbi agent gary rowe into the ku klux
klan
in birmingham
and what i've described so far sounds
pretty good but
while he was part of the klu klux klan
in order to maintain
his credibility
he had to both witness
acts of violence
by the clan and indeed at times
participate in beatings he was under
orders under no circumstances was he to
initiate or lead
such you know such a violent event but
nonetheless
he couldn't hold back
because otherwise he would be be found
out
now that's a sting operation if you will
where the moral ambiguity is is pretty
profoundly troubling
and one that i don't think we've ever
quite come to terms with i'm very glad
that viola leosa's
killers were apprehended but nonetheless
the fbi had to engage in some
questionable conduct to get to that
point gregory wall lance is our guest
former assistant u.s attorney from new
york 1979 to 1985 we're talking about
the abscam investigation
pardon me of the late 70s and early 80s
it's tie-in to the american hustle movie
we're going to put the numbers up on the
screen if you'd like to dial in if you
have any questions about this go ahead
and dial in now or you can tweet it as
well
peter is calling from nichols new york
peter good morning
yes hello good morning
uh mr wallin if you're a lawyer who's
helped prosecute government officials uh
well there's
evidence suggesting that building seven
that's the third tower that fell on 911
which wasn't hit by a plane was brought
down and controlled them we're going to
cut him off because he's not talking on
the topic that we are talking on this
morning sorry about that mr wallant
steve in coal city indiana please go
ahead with your question or comment
about abscam
uh nine billion
was cut from people
with food uh for food stamps
eighty billion was given for subsidies
for for the uh
for banks
now my question is is is this because
that people with banks could afford to
buy
or influence congress whereas the ones
with food stamps had no source for this
this uh
for this infra for this money mr
willance if we take that a little bit
further uh
just to just to talk about congressional
influence at this point
is it still possible to connect money to
politicians
absolutely and it's unavoidable and and
here's the ambiguity that i think uh
abscam revealed which which may partly
answer the question
uh which is that there's a very fine
line
between lawful campaign contributions
and bribery
and and the reason it arises is because
politicians
are in the business that is elected
legislators are in the business of
introducing legislation perfectly normal
that's what they're expected to do
and they're also in the business of
running for office and therefore having
to raise money to run for office and the
distinction is this
a donor may give money
to a congressman with the expectation
that the congressman will introduce
legislation that will favor
his position
his goals
the congressman may know
that that's why he's been given the
money
so far
nothing illegal has has occurred but
when
the elected official
and the donor
the giver of the money have an express
agreement
that there's a quid pro quo in other
words you give me money
i'll give you the influence of my office
then they've crossed the line and that's
bribery and in the examples you're
citing i don't know
if if that occurred i can i can just say
generally that there's a perception
among the american public
uh in fact the cnn poll indicated that
85 percent just a few years ago 85
percent of the american public believe
that
congressmen legislators are influenced
heavily influenced if not
controlled by
uh the people who fund their campaigns
but this distinction is what abscam was
focused on and
when you look at these tapes
uh when you read the accounts of what
the congressman said there was no
question and that was a real issue for
the jury that they were engaged in a
quid pro quo you give me money i'll
introduce legislation that will get the
sheik a visa to live in the united
states permanently so he doesn't have to
worry about unrest and upheaval in the
middle east that's crossing the line
laura tweets into you why do they call
it abscam
well initially it was reported
erroneously as arab scam
and that provoked among other
controversies
protests from middle eastern countries
in fact
abscam stood for abdul scam
and there were two sheiks
represented or played by different fbi
agents
and one the sheik the first one was
abdul rahman and he set up abdul
enterprises as his investment operation
in the united states
and the the operation became known as
abdul scam abscam
but the arab scam kind of stuck in
people's minds and and caused a lot of i
guess a diplomatic event
jd reading wants to know via twitter can
mr wallins
comment on the politicians that refused
the money
well
yeah they were corrupt
and that was established that had to be
established to convict them
beyond a reasonable doubt i i think
though that there was a range of style
in in in how they approached the corrupt
proposition offered by the undercover
operatives i described the ones who were
pretty blatant about it and really
didn't leave a lot to the imagination
but there were others for example who
were a lot more careful wary and crafty
and for example uh
one congressman was sitting in the hotel
room which where the videotapes were
recording what was taking place with mel
weinberg and another fbi agent
pretending to be the sheik's
representatives
and
they discussed the immigration
legislation that they were seeking to
have the congressman introduced to help
the she come to the united states and
then they passed across
to the congressman
a suitcase
with fifty thousand dollars and one
hundred dollar bills
the congressman looked at the suitcase
and then turned to the lawyer who
accompanied him and said howard why
don't you take care of that for me
so he was very careful and that the
issue at his trial was whether he knew
what was in that suitcase was cash
being paid in return for his legislative
favor
ultimately the jury concluded from all
of the circumstances that he had to know
that this was cash and convicted him
but i was struck by the range of of
approaches
that the congressman took in
in dealing with the undercover
operatives
31
officials targeted
seven convictions correct
uh no i think it was almost every
official
who and target isn't quite quite the
right word
who
met with the undercover agents listened
to their illegal proposals and agreed to
them
virtually all of them were convicted
they were the sixth congressman the
united states senator
there were three members of the
philadelphia city councilman the mayor
of camden new jersey angel eric cady
who's also state senator and and a
number of other lesser officials i
i can't recall if virtually every jury
returned to conviction but the vast vast
majority of them did yeah i apologize i
meant seven from capitol hill were uh
convicted one senator seven congress uh
six congressmen how many did they all
serve jail time how long were they in
jail
they all served jail time and they were
in jail for at least several years
and harrison williams was the sole us
senator that got convicted and again mr
wallins why did some
non-congressional members
of city councils etc get involved in
this
fbi sting well i i i referred earlier to
the networking
and
sort of at the the outer circle
were the these low-level crooks
who then who were selling stolen art or
selling selling stolen cds who then uh
put the undercover operation
in touch with sort of the next level
and that was angelo erichetti
and corrupt lawyers
and the corrupt city councilman
and
they in turn
after satisfying themselves that they
were dealing with
authentically corrupt uh
and authentically corrupt arab sheikh uh
then passed the undercover agents or set
up meetings for the undercover
team with the congressman and the
senator
so it was this networking from the outer
circles to the inner circles
that is what really
made abscam so effective
alathia quick tweets in why were these
politicians targeted and
what triggered the investigation now
we've covered a little bit of that but
please go ahead and revisit that but
again was there a targeting of specific
officials or was this going to be wide
open to all 535 members of the congress
of the congress
yeah that's a good question and in the
first instance though there was no
targeting of an official
the the undercover operation simply
continued when they were said when let's
say angela ericketti says i want to
introduce you to a congressman who can
help the sheikh with legislation
it would have been a dereliction
of their law enforcement duties if they
said no we don't we don't want to meet
with him
they they had to meet with them and this
goes back to what i said that there's
nothing wrong with
setting up an opportunity or the means
for someone to commit a crime provided
you don't induce him to do something
that he wasn't predisposed to do
and so that that is not targeting that
simply good
good
good law
enforcement and and separately i think
uh
these um
these congressmen
uh
you know were were sort of
you know they set up a ruse and and the
ruse was as follows they would meet with
the congress and they'd sort of have a
party somewhere and then they'd explain
i'm sorry with the congressman's
representatives the lawyers and they
sort of explained to them
well
we represent the arab sheik and
he's very concerned about unrest in the
middle east
and
he would like to know that if he needed
to have in the united states he could
come here
and we hear that
congressmen have the ability to
introduce special legislation special
immigration bills to help just one
individual come to the united states
and these lawyers or the city councilman
or the mayor would say
well we know someone
who can help you
and the undercover agents would say well
money's no object
they just sat back and the next thing
they knew
these congressmen were brought into
hotel rooms the plaza hotel at a kennedy
airport
or a rented house in washington d.c
and
they would explain the undercover
operatives would simply explain this is
what we'd like to do this is the
legislation we need
and the sheik is willing
to reward you for this and then they
pass the money over
that wasn't so that's not targeting
that was simply to my to my mind anyway
i think good law enforcement and as i
indicated all of the courts that
reviewed this
uh agreed that this was appropriate law
enforcement
conduct
delbert columbus ohio please go ahead
with your question for gregory will
lance
yes i would like to know uh were those
uh i like the question and comment i'd
like to know if those people that were
convicted were they whether on the
democrat
majority or was it
bipartisan
and what's your comment delbert
my comment is the level of
investigations between
uh
democrats and republicans because i
think at that particular same time
weren't there a snl scandal
that was that the investigation didn't
go very far because
not only did ronald reagan have
involvement in the snl scandal but so
did george w bush which cost the
american taxpayers 1.4 trillion dollars
all right thank you sir
uh gregory wallins
well
uh
of the six congressmen and the united
states senator who were convicted
uh only one was a republican congressman
kelly from florida the rest were
democrats but i i think it's too
small a sample size to draw any
conclusions from and and that goes back
to a question peter
you asked me that i'm not certain i got
to which was
what would have happened if the
investigation had just gone on and on
and on
would all
565 congressmen have been convicted
i doubt it would have involved something
like that but at the same time
the investigation
had it gone on longer
who can say how many more congressmen
it would have established were corrupt
and were you know not
were predisposed to take bribes and it
ended
because uh the number of factors one was
that the undercover agents were simply
exhausted they were doing so many
meetings so many
uh
bribes so many discussions so much money
was being promised it just became at a
certain point it just became unwieldy
and so they decided to to close it down
at least the undercover phase and then
of course the there was a leak
of a prosecution memorandum and that's
what resulted in the
in the television news report that you
started the program with
and so we never found out
how many
were corrupt how many more were out
there just waiting for the opportunity
to uh to take a bribe
and it's a kind of a lingering question
it's not as though uh there haven't been
any incidents of political corruption
both in congress and at the state level
uh since then or in recent years there
have there have been quite a few
incidents
but without getting
into the organization itself in an
undercover
capacity
you really can't know they tend to be a
little bit more isolated abscam was
unusual because it got into congress it
got behind the scenes
got behind the closed doors
it showed you what was happening and the
fact that these congressmen
acted so matter-of-factly and the way
they went about taking
the bribes
was troubling and that's the unanswered
question of appscam how many more
were willing to do that if they were
given the opportunity
jack tweets in looking back do you feel
abscam had any effect
pardon me did it in fact change the
culture or not
i think it had an impact it was so
visible it was so uh searing both for
congress and for the congressman that
it had to have had some deterrent effect
people would be a little more hesitant i
think
to engage with
at least not with doing more due
diligence than any of these people did
with the
very overtly corrupt people willing to
pay bribes at the same time
law enforcement at any level political
corruption or narcotics is is a bit of a
treadmill you're never going to
eliminate crime you're never going to
eliminate corruption or dishonesty and
so
it never it never totally changes the
culture
uh but it's i think it's vital to have
effective law enforcement and again i
stress that
thing operations like this need to be
managed carefully with good judgment
uh
and when they are they play an important
role in
deterring this kind of conduct and it's
important at another level which is you
really can't have a democracy
if your elected officials are corrupt
and so that's why i think at the end of
the day what abscam did was was very
important in reminding people that we
have to be ever vigilant about political
corruption mr wallance do you think that
john murtha was guilty
i think john martha is entitled to the
presumption of innocence he was not
charged
and therefore
beyond that i don't think
anybody in law enforcement or former law
enforcement
should be should be speculating what did
this investigation cost u.s taxpayers
i'm not i honestly peter i don't know
what the figures were there was i can
tell you the final figures were i can
tell you there was a huge battle that
the movie kind of got at
between
the the people running the sting
operation who wanted to spend a lot of
money
to create the illusion
of the wealthy chic they wanted to have
the best rooms at the plaza hotel and
all kinds of uh fancy uh accoutrements
that would go with it versus their
superiors in washington who kept
fighting back and saying we've got to
live within certain budgetary
constraints and it it resulted in some
near uh well almost hilarious events
there was one meeting
where
perhaps to save money and the sheik was
present perhaps not thinking it through
instead of having some lavish spread
with caviar and champagne
the undercover operatives ordered in
food was jewish deli food
now that should have put
the
targets the the crooks they were dealing
with i noticed that there's something
peculiar here why is the sheik ordering
jewish deli food
to serve his guests and mel weinberg who
was very good at salvaging these
situations and there were quite a few
and this is where you know he was so
important to the to the operation he
would just kind of wave it off and say
hey look you know when when he's in the
middle east the sheik can't eat jewish
jelly food but he loves it so when he
comes here he's got an opportunity to
eat it
and all these people
so interested in
the financial opportunities that
abdul enterprises were presenting them
with
just
accepted that never questioned it
walter is calling from st john's arizona
hi walter uh good morning mr wallons
good to see you on c-span today i had a
two-part quest morning
uh as we know on criminals uh there's
always the dumb and then there's a smart
on the aspect of targeting you know take
a cash brag here's the bundle of cash
most of the smart will just turn their
back and walk away
the uh
down will say oh cash let me run with it
but i've noticed i've watched for many a
decade the big money
i mean we're talking tens of millions
hundreds of millions of dollars
change his hands not in cash
but if a bribe or to get someone elected
is held out as the bribe they'll do it
through soft money
where
say a deals cut there's a five million
dollar piece of property
well you can buy it for five hundred
thousand dollars
we'll do it through a hong kong
corporation will just look like good
business
and the money is paid out made that way
on the aspect of getting someone elected
you know there's restrictions as far as
how much you can attribute to a campaign
if i called up a congressman said
my corporation will spend 300 million
dollars
to get you elected we're not going to
have any association with your campaign
we can spend as much as we want
there's no restriction
how actively has your investigation or
any investigation looked into the
business transactions
of congressman to to pinpoint
those bribes that are taking place where
it's
a business deal or
soft money being spent
based on the conversation
that i mentioned that's where the smart
criminal operates in that arena on the
aspect of just cash being handed over
that's the dumb side so if you could
address at one point regarding business
transactions real estate transactions
i would love to hear your comments
well you know there's a saying
it isn't what's illegal that shocks you
about
money and
politicians it's what's legal
it's really shocking
and i think what you're describing
is
is sort of more on the legal side the
soft money how uh loopholes in election
fundraising laws can be circumvented
shall we say
that is certainly the topic of debate
uh
abscam wasn't targeting
uh and wasn't looking at uh soft money
it was it was looking as you put it at
that at the dumb people those who were
willing to take cash bribes although in
one instance and that was
uh us senator harrison williams that
involved more of the kind of
sophisticated scheme
that you're raising
it wasn't a cash bribe in a hotel room
he and his colleagues associates
some of them were
notoriously corrupt
had an interest in a titanium mine
and titanium is a rare metal was part of
the government stockpile
and the senator's interest was actually
hidden but they all had this interest in
a titanium mine
and so what developed in a year's worth
of discussions
with the undercover operatives
was a proposal that really came from the
senator's side
that
the sheikh
would invest
a hundred million in the titanium line
in return to ensure that his investment
would be successful senator williams
would use his influence and he was a
very powerful senator 13th in seniority
in the senate at that time to get the
u.s government to buy titanium from the
mine
for
the strategic stockpile
and this went on for a year
and papers were actually drawn up
as sort of the the process of creating a
a company that would receive the money
from the sheik and so on and they were
very elaborate discussions of how this
mine would be structured who the
ownership would be and and so on and the
senator came in and met personally with
the sheik and assured him
he said well i'm not going to be a
senator forever
and
assured him that he would make the
venture profitable by using his
influence
i know the president i deal one-on-one
with him
to
get contracts to sell titanium to the
u.s strategic stockpile
but again that wasn't soft money as
you're describing it that wasn't legal
soft money and it was more in the dumb
category although it was a very very
sophisticated scheme and probably more
what the very cagey careful
corrupt politician would want to do
to try to
insulate himself
as much as possible from uh charges of
bribe taking
how long did uh senator williams spend
in prison
uh it was several years that he spent in
prison
and you know there was no in this case
again the word target keeps coming up
there wasn't any targeting he was
introduced to the undercover operatives
by uh
mayor eric hetti
uh and
his uh his lawyer
another a new new jersey uh
figure uh who had been linked to
organized crime
and corrupt acts
were the ones who initiated brought to
the attention of the undercover
operatives this titanium iron and
indicated the center had an interest and
that's where this whole thing evolved
mr wallins susan jeffries asks did
anyone offer a offered a bribe in ab
scam take the money and immediately turn
it into the fbi and report the bribery
attempt
in a word no
and neither did those who turned down
the bribe
and in fact just to go back to senator
williams
at one point and this was something that
his defense attempted to use at one
point in a meeting with the sheik
the sheik offered him
something like twenty thousand dollars
for personal expenses as a as a goodwill
gesture
and and williams said no no no i don't
want to take that my interest is seeing
that this titanium venture
succeeds now here's the united states
senator
and
he's been confronted
with an act and legal act committed by
a representative a foreigner
in the united states
and nonetheless
makes it clear he wants to continue
doing business with him
and ultimately with all the controversy
that abscam generated
in the end i think what moved the juries
and the courts that reviewed the
convictions
is simply that the american people
had a right to expect
that their congressmen
this senator their elected officials
would not behave in this manner
when confronted
with these very corrupt proposals
charlie lanham maryland please go ahead
with your question or comment about
abscam
good morning mr wallace uh i was an
auditor as working as a contractor for
the environmental protection agency and
we used your files to
go after a bunch of state and i'm sorry
local officials municipalities mainly in
new jersey connecticut and we got some
cost recoveries because of your work
uh
you guys we're looking at uh
12 14 16 different
corrupt mayors so i'm only interested in
local local politics local corruption
anyway there was a engineer who
owned a 250 person firm
who was shaken down contractors uh with
change orders
on epa work and then he was
using those bribes that he got from the
shakedowns i'm sorry using the money he
got from the shakedowns to bribe
politicians to get more work do you
remember him he i think he ultimately
committed suicide he was a quite a
character can you talk to that
you know unfortunately i i i can't
i think that was an aspect of the case
that i i simply wasn't involved in but
what it illustrates
was the way that
abdul enterprises these fbi agents and
mel weinberg
were able to so effectively
network in the underworld that the sort
of the tentacles went out in in of their
their uh their shadow if it were
the word of what they were about
spread so wide that they started getting
all of these
these potentially corrupt or actually
corrupt
politicians or politicians
representatives or
government officials
interested in them coming to them and
it's one of the reasons they became
exhausted as i described was that they
were fielding so many proposals trying
to keep track of so many different
meetings because lots of meetings are
involved in setting something up
uh and and it went on to a point that
they just became overwhelmed by it
and that's the unanswered question which
we
we alluded to earlier which is well if
they managed to keep it going long
enough
how many how much more political
corruption would have been
uncovered we'll never know the answer to
that the result of abscam as far as
fbi procedures what changed
well
not surprisingly there was considerable
unhappiness in congress
with abscam now a number of these
congressmen who didn't resign
were
in effect uh forced out of congress
expelled from congress and congress had
to address that
but both the senate and the house began
investigations of the and held hearings
on the undercover operation
and concluded that the department of
justice and the fbi
needed to tighten
control over these kinds of
sting operations
and the result was that
a special
level of approval became needed
when an undercover operation
was going to be focusing on high level
and as well
and i think this was the case probably
all along but
there was there couldn't be any
targeting
uh without at least
in others focusing on a specific
official without at least a reasonable
suspicion
that the official
had engaged or was prepared to engage
without
you know
had a predisposition to engage
in corrupt activities now i think
that level of initial suspicion existed
in abscam and probably a lot of the
undercover
investigations that had taken place but
nonetheless this kind of came became
embedded in the um
in the guidelines for undercover
operations so that was one
uh impact that appscam had
and finally dean tweets in could abscam
be considered the first sting seen by
the public from hidden cameras
it's a good question i think so it's
certainly on this scale the use of the
videotapes
hadn't been
uh used to to my recollection in in such
a
a major
operation and the technology you know
sort of came together and they could you
know put the camera in a room next to
the room where the politician was
meeting with the undercover team and
just through a pinhole
uh get a get a reasonably good by the
standards of the day videotape and of
course the videotapes the courtrooms at
the trials you know they had 13
cam a television sets defense table
prosecution table the judge the jurors
sometimes they had their own tv sets it
was just like a wired courtroom and it
had a huge impact on the jury so but in
a certain sense one impact of abscam was
that after that
juries particularly in
these kinds of political corruption
cases
wanted to see the videotapes and it kind
of put a greater burden
on prosecutors who didn't have
videotaped evidence that was so clear
uh to come forward and and
and make their case now of course we
live in an age when it seems like
everything is caught digitally
uh on cell phones and and and so on
uh and uh
almost everything is recorded but then
it was novel and it was something of a
breakthrough technique
mr wallins what are you doing today
well thanks i'm i'm in private practice
i i represent both
defendants and civil cases
as well as uh white-collar uh defendants
mostly companies caught up not so much
in political corruption but in other
kinds of uh investigations
uh and uh you know pretty much enjoying
myself and uh
really um have good memories of of
appscam at the same time and american
hustle kind of brought it all back it's
a great movie i hope it gets the oscar
for best picture
uh and i thought the line at the
beginning
summed it up where they put on the
screen before the movie starts
some of this actually happened
and that was the part that i had
the good fortune to be involved with so
when you watch american hustle what
percentage would you say is realistic
oh that's a it's hard to put a
percentage on it
uh
and and they used they took bits and
pieces
from the real life app scam and sort of
blew them up but i i would say that
the two biggest departures from history
is one i've already discussed and that
was the portrayal of angelo erichetti in
a somewhat sympathetic way and the
second was the
portrayal of one of the fbi agents as
sort of a little
off the charts he put his hair up in
curlers he was trying to have an affair
or had an affair with
the mel weinberg characters uh mistress
uh and and generally behaved in an
outlandish way and that wasn't really a
fair characterization of the fbi agents
who were very professional very focused
very mindful
of the need to
avoid entrapment
and at the same time to get good
evidence so they were fairly prosecuting
a particular official
uh and never behaved in that in in the
manner uh portrayed in the in the movie
and i understand
you know the artistic license that
movies have but that's one where
uh
historically
it was not an accurate portrayal
in the 30-some years since the abscam
investigations and convictions have you
met with any of the
former members of congress
no i i haven't
and i'm not certain they would welcome
an opportunity to meet with me or anyone
on the prosecution or investigation side
of the of the case
and a number of them have have have
passed away at the same time gregory
wallins
talking about abscam and american hustle
thank you for your time this
morning sir we appreciate it peter
coming up next a discussion about
veterans benefits the current status of
that veterans benefits with tom
tarantino of the iraq and afghanistan